story like the form a story is why you
become a journalist probably the most
rewarding thing I think I'll ever do
it's good i mean the platform is is huge
I have half million to nearly two
million people will read an article
depending on sort of how much it's
promoted or whether it makes the front
page or not story like the corn maze
story is why you become a journalist
probably the most rewarding thing I
think I'll ever do and you know seeing
him home with his kids at that
homecoming was amazing he was such you
know a great father by all accounts and
then he's pulled away from them for ten
years and and then gets reunited and it
was just it was it was pretty awesome
senior editor of Reason magazine Radley
Balko claims Haynes testimony about his
findings often falls in line with what
the prosecution is trying to prove dr.
Haines is a the medical examiner who did
eighty ninety percent of the autopsy
students it be for about 20 years and
he's since been fired from prevented
from doing any more but he still
testifies down there there are all these
cases still Mississippi with involving
dr. Haines where you have you know
people who were convicted almost
exclusively because of his testimony or
that of his sidekick dr. West and you
know a significant chunk of those people
are innocent I think with the Occupy
Wall Street people it's I mean I think I
probably agree of them on most of the
problems i think they diagnosed a lot of
problems correctly but i think it's you
know the solutions where we differ the
occupiers are using social media and
cell phones to actually document police
abuse and i think that's really a kind
of a powerful story to come out of this
and through the Arab Spring also which
is the technology as really empowered
citizens to keep government you know
transparent and accountable in a way you
know like never before in human history
the purpose for the Nashville blog is
I'm an opportunity to do some cultural
writing some music writing
country gospel soul jazz blues rock and
there's a really sort of thriving scene
here I mean some of the best musicians
in the world live here now it's a great
town there's still kind of the moral
kind of conservatism there's also kind
of a big city liberalism and you see it
in really sort of interesting ways I
mean there's a one of my favorite
examples is there's church street you
know which one runs right through the
city and in one part of the city that's
where a lot of the big churches in town
are then you go a little farther down
and you've got the the hustler stores
right off of Church Street and you go a
little farther down and you've got
Nashville's sort of gay district is also
on Church Street in Tennessee you have
this alcohol control board it's funded
by the fines that they levy on bars if
you're sitting on this alcohol control
board the incentive then is to hand out
all of these sort of low-level fines but
to you know sort of turn your head when
they're these really serious you know
infractions wear that are you know
possibly actually dangerous because you
know every bar that loses its licenses
one less paying customer for you so it's
really I mean you couldn't design a
system with worse incentives if you sort
of sat down and tried there's a taco
place called the taco mamacita right up
the road here they were having this huge
fight with the local government over
their liquor license all they wanted to
do was serve light beers that you know
it took so long to get the the licensed
to serve the beer they just went to the
state and got a liquor license so you
know instead of serving these light low
alcohol content beers they get in this
bureaucratic hassle and now they're just
serving liquor
you